[موسيقى
] أواصل رحلتي عبر
مشهد الجولف في آيسلندا وأتجه جنوبًا
خارج العاصمة ريكيافيك
على بعد رحلة قصيرة بالعبارة من
البر الرئيسي ، تقع جزر ويستمان ، هذا
الأرخبيل قبالة الساحل الجنوبي لأيسلندا الذي
يشتهر
بالحياة البرية الرائعة والمناظر الطبيعية الخلابة  كلها
مزورة ومحددة من خلال
نشاط البراكين ، ولكن في الآونة الأخيرة
أصبحت شيئًا من مكة
بالنسبة للاعبي الجولف الذين يزورون
آيسلندا داخل فوهة بركانية ضخمة ،
فإن العرض في
نادي ويستمان آيلاندز للغولف هو مكان فريد ومذهل
للجولف  كما من المحتمل أن
تجد في أي مكان في العالم
تأسس في عام
1938 ، يعمل النادي هنا كنقطة محورية
لسكان الجزر المحبين للجولف ،
كان هناك رجلان هنا
في وستمنستر ، نبدأ بالثقوب الستة
ثم نبني  حتى تسعة حفر ، ثم
هذا الآن 18 حفرة ،
كارل هارلسون هو النادي المحترف هنا
وقد نشأ في الجزر يعرف
تمامًا مدى أهمية النادي
للشباب.  الناس والمجتمع ،
هناك العديد من الشباب الذين يلعبون الجولف ،
لدينا هنا في هذا النادي
19 عضوًا تبلغ أعمارهم 116 عامًا ،
وهو أمر جيد جدًا لهذا النادي الصغير جدًا ، لقد
بدأت في الخامسة من عمري
مع
أصدقائي في البداية ونحن  هل يمكننا
المجيء إلى هنا لأن هذا أه
يمكن لكل عضو أن يلعب
مثل العديد من الأشخاص في الجزيرة ، يمتلك كارل
روابط قوية جدًا بالصناعة الرئيسية
هنا
عندما كنت في العشرين من عمري
لأكون صيادًا كنت هناك لمدة 10 سنوات
جيدًا وكان ذلك
أيضًا  حياة جيدة ، أنت تعرف راتبًا
جيدًا وهناك تذكير بأيام صيد كارل
في الحفرة المميزة
هنا في النادي ، يوجد 17 شابًا ،
هذه فتحة توقيع
وهذا هو
عملي على هذا القارب لمدة 12 12 عامًا
وهذا الاسم هنا  كيم يشرب النساء
منذ أكثر من 10 سنوات
بقليل منذ أكثر من 10 سنوات بقليل ،
إنه أول شخص يقدس
في هذه الحفرة المميزة
وكان قبطان القارب
وكان قبطانًا على القارب
يمكنني بأمان  أقول أن لدي ني  تم
لعب ver في مكان مثل هذا تمامًا مع
وجود بركان خامد خلفي محاط
بحمم قديمة
والجزء الثالث هو الفتحة المميزة
هنا
في ملعب الجولف الجميل هذا ،
كما تعلمون ، تعد لعبة الجولف في أيسلندا تجربة فريدة من نوعها ،
فأنت النادي
رائع
الجمال.
ودود ، شكرًا لك ، شكرًا لك هذه
المتعة
، مكان رائع رائع ،
نرحب به دائمًا ، نعم ، مرحبًا بك في منزلي ،
فلدي أعود